你以为拍短视频赚钱,靠的是灵感,其实不是
这两个差,也不是信息差,一个信差
我已经举了一个字,你马上明白了
比如说,放上中线,拜访他的靠什么?靠靠贪,靠能说嘛,其实不是
首先,第一个是防元,然后,其实不要整个透明话的流程,这个叫信息差
篩选,支持,把整个法律的整个跟中,这个叫信息差
所以,我们在中线买房子,消除的是不确定性
所以我们在拍内容的时候,也是有两个差的
首先,第一个就是看的内容可以接着我的时间
可以消除我,我把自己要去摸错,要还能接我自己,不知道
还有一种方式的话,就是我有信感,通过这个事情,我马上就跟取得简直过
如果明白这两点的话,你就知道
那种从哪来,灵干从哪来,两个东西,第一个东西就是你自己的通报
所以很远说,按摩,我学一来半天学不会,我拍拖任平,我不知道怎么才会拍了半天,没有两个告诉你,这都是好事
为什么?因为你遇断的问题,别人都会遇断的
所以只要遇断的第一件事情,就是把它气度下来,这个是资产
然后想办法这些圆
然后你遇断的东西,对别人都说,帮助的,而是这个东西,反正很可信的,这个叫信任差
另外一个的话,就是经验
经验什么,是你不意见证的,这个东西是有效的,所以每天花点时间去读经验
但是读的时候,不是理解的句话
而是说,这句话还可以那什么地方,比如说我理解的这个iX的概念,它可以用在外场里,大概可以得到自己的结果
然后我就尝试,然后厌证这句话是OK的
好的,有在这两点,可以
你基本上就可以通过短日,就尝试了
比如说就是,你就会有一个结果,你刚才不是有信息的来源,就像大属有那个菜一样
然后你就有一个过程,做他的过程,然后就会把他变成一个可以消失的产品,那么这个过程是什么呢?就是一个结果,比如说,就像第一个差是什么
然后就是证据
然后就是方法,然后是厌证,然后靠短的,就是
早半你一起形容,我们几个小历史,比如说差是什么,第一个部分就是
我不知道我该拍什么东西,我不知道我有什么东西都拍的
对吧,这个叫差
对,你知道问题怎么差吗?我知道你不知道吗?对吧,第二个事情就是证据,你知道吗?其实我以前拍的,你那时候也不知道怎么拍
拍两个三个小时,一并别出一周是平,根本就没着亮
这种事情我大概坚持了
好久的月,你看我们,你看我之前拍的视频,你看
这一会就是你过往的经历,这就是证据
大家哦,原来你也这个样子,这就是现任差就被消除了
然后说,我告诉你个方法,后来我找这个方法
我用这个方法是怎么解决的,比如说,我就是把我自己语了一些痛苦,就切到下来,后来我就想办法解决,到时候找个方案解决
然后解决,然后我是怎么做的,然后我告诉大家,你有这个问题吗?
我告诉你我有一个方法,可以怎么能做,然后解决,就用这个公司解决
你知道,你就告诉我,不愿该怎么做,最后的话,你可以试试,才用这个方法,你看,这就是一个很好的结果
所以各位到底该怎么拍短片,那两个重要的输入,一个是你的痛苦,那个都是你的资产,你千万不要放过另外一个就是经历
然后痛过一个结果,不断的固定地把它输入出来,两个差,所以拍短视频,赚钱,不靠灵感,靠两个差,一个是信息差,一个是信差